ich habe Sandra gerade mal gemutet ich
kann euch sagen heute kommt ein prank wo
wir uns richtig darauf vorbereitet haben
wie ein Mod von mir hat das auf dem
Server installiert und es wird richtig
lustig das machen wir aber erst nachdem
wir die enderperlen gesammelt haben das
sind aber krass das muss man also da
müssten wir dabei sein das ist Fakt
Leute wie viel Perlen brauchen wir voll
real
also damit wir so auf Nummer safe gehen
sage ich mal mit 16 bist du Safe mit 14
ist so Basti Level 12 ist riskant dass
du noch mal in den nethermoster ach du
scheiße ja wir sind ja schon eher Basti
Level würde ich sagen dann baut ein Haus
mit Erde ein
stimmt nicht oder
meine Currywurst wo du ein bisschen
weiter ich kann mir das auch nicht
vorstellen bin in der Hölle für uns und
du mich da zu Hause pranks
Leute
gehen wir ab wieder zurück in die
Oberwelt bei euch freue mich schon so
darauf
sandra hat das Portal abgebaut ja Zähler
ich weiß nicht wie war das oh mein Gott
direkt zwei bekommen wir haben es wir
können wieder zurück so Leute wie komme
ich jetzt hier raus Notfall kann Sandra
gehen und dir mit F3 Koordinaten geben
ja aber wir haben schon genug geschieht
und das möchte ich eigentlich nicht ja
oder wollen wir das machen mit Sandra
sollen in netter gehen und dann mir die
Koordinaten geben das ist kein cheaten
ja okay dann machen wir das so okay
selfie dann geh du mal jetzt in den
Nether keine Ahnung
und dann F4
[Musik]
Sandra ja krass mein ganzes Haus voll
mit Erde ne
[Musik]
echt
hey leiser
verpiss Dich ey warum ist das denn voll
mit Erde kennst du dieses Erdrutsch
nicht
oh nein ich finde es auch stark
dass du mich einfach jetzt so schon auch
schon ein paar mal geprankt dass in
Minecraft
[Musik]
versteht ihr uns auch obwohl in Dialekt
habt
ja
bist du dumm
Leute das muss reichen oder das doch
richtig ne das wird 19 Ende Augen haben
oder guck mal hier hin
guck mal was mit meiner enderperle
machen kann stell dich mal genau hier
auf die Kante
achte mal da hinten auf ähm man braucht
doch jetzt kein enderperle wir haben
genug
diese Pferdestall ja guck mal auf den
Pferdestall okay
[Musik]
ich komme wieder zurück zu dir
krass krass ja theoretisch können wir
das Ende direkt schon suchen Leute oder
hat zu Beginn möchte ich aber noch mal
ganz kurz was machen lass mal kurz noch
hier vorne gehen
so Leute ich habe jetzt gerade mal alle
vier Betten abgebaut damit ich Sandra
gleich töten kann am spawnen damit ich
genau weiß wo dann der Spawn ist in den
Raum gehen um einfach zu checken ob der
Weg du hast doch geschlafen ich will was
testen wenn wir sterben will ich dass du
wiederkommen
okay Leute ich habe gerade
Sandra getötet und vorher ihr Bett
abgebaut und zu schauen wo sie respawnt
das war ja irgendwo hier deswegen will
ich den ganzen Bereich jetzt hier
aushebeln
um
die in einem Loch vorne zu lassen nicht
allzu tief aber die spawnt auf jeden
Fall auf einer Höhe wo sie keine Blöcke
haben wird um sich hoch zu bauen und ähm
dementsprechend habe ich mich jetzt ganz
entspannt hier raus werde dann noch mal
töten um sie dann hier sonst zu sehen
komm mal kurz zurück eben zu dem
Spawn
[Musik]
[Applaus]
hast du mich die ganze Zeit
hä ja ich muss ein paar Sachen testen
gerade fürs Ende ob der Pfeil und Bogen
funktioniert und so wie kann es denn
sein dass die vorhin das Bauen und jetzt
hier ich brauche Nummer 33 wir haben es
ja eins zu eins gesehen dass ich hierher
kam dass sie hier geboren gar nichts ne
klappt nicht
komplett aus Leute ich habe einen
kranken prank noch geplant wirklich das
wird der krasseste prank den wir bisher
jemals hatten weil wir dafür ein Plugin
installieren mussten das wird also der
prank wird irre machen wir gleich
erstmal suchen das Ende
[Musik]
oh mein Gott die maximale Bauhöhe
beträgt 319 ich habe die maximale Höhe
erreicht hat sich jemand schon mal so
hoch gebaut ich glaube das Weltrekord
dann springen wir jetzt runter gucken
das sind tragischer Tod
und traurig ich sehe dich ja so sehr bei
so einer Assi schaue
nein
ich bin gemutet und mich interessiert es
einfach nicht Sendung ja ich will es
nicht wissen
[Musik]
ist mir egal
warum nicht Leute wollt ihr es wissen
20 Sekunden später
[Musik]
nein du sollst nicht sagen
dass du ganz genau
allen gesagt die sollen schreiben nein
ich glaube wohl kaputt zu Ende
zu erklären wir brauchen die Änderung
und das Ende zu finden deswegen ich
werde jetzt eine hoch und die zeigt uns
den Weg bist du bereit
die kam jetzt wieder zurück das heißt
wir müssen in diese Richtung fahren
hinter das Portal let's go auf geht's
Leute seid ihr bereit für den prank
jetzt gerade bei der perfekte Moment um
den zu machen soll ich machen hol mal
kurz ein bisschen Holz sich um auch hier
vorne Holz und während Sandra jetzt sah
das Holz abbaut ich verstecke mich im
Wald und mache jetzt den prank
Schrägstrich CP und jetzt verwandeln wir
uns in ein Tier und zwar
in ein Schwein ich kann mich in alles
verwandeln ich kann mich sogar den
Enderdrachen verwandeln wir haben es
installiert Leute ich tue jetzt werde
ich ein Schwein mal schauen ob es andere
mich schlägt hast du Holz
ja
wie viel
acht
irgendwas
[Musik]
Alter was will denn der Schweine jetzt
von mir sorry habe gerade ganz kurzen
Kaffee mit dem Schwein
ein Kampf mit dem Schwein
[Musik]
[Applaus]